why were you able to get some sort of
early success on on the business
development side do you think what I
realized is very good at and it's the
ability to be ruthlessly tenacious if
you think about bodybuilding and
translating the bodybuilding world to
Business Development when I was
competing you do a 12-week cut two weeks
out I was doing an hour on the
StairMaster three four times a week as
well as doing weight training like seven
eight times a week when you go through
the period And this is interesting
because I use this as an analogy to my
Consultants it's translating a process
which works into business development
when you're on the StairMaster the first
five minutes you're thinking I've got
this and then the next families you're
thinking why I've started then you get
halfway thinking I just want to start
but can I get going then you get to 40
minutes you're like I've got this and
that first part of the journey is always
the hardest bit with business
development and it's just like being on
the StairMaster or whatever your
interest is whatever's hot translate
that to Business Development